this video is brought to you by
manscape.com
ladies gentlemen and everyone i think we
may just be onto something here with
this theory one piece has been a beloved
story in pop culture for over two
decades from its humble opening chapters
to the cataclysmic clashes of the modern
material the series has become the
single best selling manga of all time
and eight year old the cheeky monkey has
been peppering this story with intrigue
and smoking guns from the very beginning
begging for us the fans of the series to
speculate and try to solve his magnum
opus's greatest mysteries like when will
we see the one piece treasure or how
will this story end but what if i told
you we might actually have the answers
every volume of the one piece manga
after volume 4 features a question
corner or sbs where author h ora takes
the time to answer fans questions and
reveals more intricacies of the world
and characters he's created oda's
answers are usually both comedic and
detailed in nature ranging from
categorical information regarding age
and measurements to playful banter with
fans but in volume 42 which was released
in 2006 just nine years into publication
oda received a different sort of
question one far more loaded than any he
had previously received it asks simply
whether oda had thought of bringing the
series to an end his response was as
follows i answered this question during
some interview but one piece was
originally supposed to be a five year
story i've always had the last chapter
in my mind but it's taken longer than
five years to build up the storyline and
so the pirates have been on a nine-year
adventure and i don't know how much
longer it will take nearly 14 years have
passed since that response and as one
piece finally reaches and passes the
long-awaited chapter 1000 the question
still remains
how and when will the series actually
end it's a question that has lingered in
the back of fans minds for decades and
one that somehow gets harder and harder
to answer as we close in on that
ultimate goal oda himself has recently
stated that he believes the series will
end in the next five years and that
statement has been met with a healthy
dose of skepticism from the one piece
fan base but what if it's an accurate
estimate what if all the series the
secrets will be revealed in the next
five years but more specifically what if
i told you that the one piece fan base
has had the secret to figuring out what
the end of the series entails at their
fingertips this entire time what if we
already know what the final chapter will
look like just like
oda himself welcome to the video
everyone i'm totally not mark and today
i'm taking my deepest dive yet into the
structure of the expansive one-piece
series attempting to unravel its secrets
and hopefully to reveal the narrative
flow for the end of one of the greatest
stories ever told
this is the checkered fate theory how
one piece will end
but first a warning this theory has
already proven effective in privately
predicting a few recent events among my
friend group and some fans might not
want future plot details spoiled in any
way shape or form and that includes
anime watchers i mean we'll be touching
on juano's current developments as well
so to those of you that wish to remain
blind to the structure of this series
proper please turn back now or use the
time codes down below appropriately now
to business as it currently stands one
piece can be divided into three major
canonical sections the east blue
paradise and the new world our theory is
actually super simple but has a
tremendous amount of detail so to put it
as simply as possible we posit that the
new world arcs are perfect thematic
inversions or mirrors of the paradise
arcs and assuming our theory concerning
that portion of the story is correct we
can then look at those east blue arcs
and try to pinpoint the answers to what
lies ahead of us at the end of the
series and let me tell you one thing
that we're convinced is for certain
these inversions are not only pervasive
throughout the canon of the story but
they're intentional used primarily to
signify a progression in underlying
themes and showcase the growth of the
straw hats over their two-year time skip
from would-be greenhorn newbie wayfarers
in way over their heads during the
paradise material to the intimidating
and world-renowned pirates they are
today voyaging across the new world but
before we delve too deep into these
details some fans might be confused by
the terms east blue paradise and new
world if you know what these terms are
you can again use the time codes below
to skip to the next section of the video
i'm sure all of you who even have a
passing interest in this series will
recognize at least some of these
locations this is the east blue the
introductory portion of the story where
luffy recruits zoro nami usop and sanji
paradise is a term only ever utilized
twice throughout the series and it
specifically refers to the first half of
the grand line in volume 8 chapter 69
after defeating don krieg saving the
variety and recruiting sanji luffy says
that he declines to take zeph's log book
which detailed the former pirates
journey through the grand line luffy
preferred the sense of adventure and
wanted to find out what it was like on
his own but zeph gave one hint before he
left he said for some the grand line is
paradise and finally after the time skip
the straw hats remain in paradise for
both the return to sherboudi and the
trip to fishman island before officially
entering the new world the new world
arcs as we currently know them are as
follows there's fewer here sure but
they're all lengthy massive arcs in
their own right with some spanning more
than 100 chapters and as of writing this
video we are knee-deep in the wano
material now there is some confusion as
to whether or not fishman island should
be considered part of paradise or the
new world seeing as it's sort of
underwater and in the middle so for the
time being we'll leave both it and the
return to shabbat ark in their own
separate categories but don't worry we
will address both in due time so let's
dive into this theory and walk down
memory lane through some of the most
iconic moments from the series to
demonstrate the inversions between
paradise and the new world arcs and
perhaps once we've understood how oda
does this we might be able to use that
information to map out and predict
future events and maybe even the story's
ending cool
cool and so on this quest for answers
let's start where we currently are in
canon and work backwards towards the
beginning we're starting with wano and
more specifically act three long time
fans of the series might know that wano
has been in oda's head for a long long
time perhaps not necessarily by name but
the island itself definitely existed
somewhere in his head the origin of sea
prism stone was first teased all the way
back during alabasta when smoker luffy
zoro nami and usop were all caged by
crocodile smoker said at the time that
the tip of his primary weapon was made
of sea prism stone which could only be
found in one place in the ocean that we
now know is wano we know that the
stone's origin was always supposed to be
one oh because smoker's weapon is a duty
which is a specialized weapon used by
the police in the edo period of japan
such careful thinking proves that wano
always had a special place in canon
which is fitting as 1 0 just happens to
be an inversion of the biggest climax in
the series so far
marine ford
spoiler warning the following short
section examines portions of the manga
that as of writing this video have not
yet been adapted into the anime yet so
if you're an anime only and wish to stay
that way you can use the time codes
below to skip to the anime friendly
material it's no secret that oda has
hyped up the 108 to be a marine ford
level event but what happens if we
directly compare locations let's dive
with onigishima does its structure look
familiar i mean it should it's nearly
identical and structured to marine fort
itself with a circular ocean inlet
positioned directly in front of a main
building but these are just visual
similarities to understand how these two
arcs are mirror images of one another we
have to compare both inversions on
okushima the pirates snuck in through
the main entrance relatively undetected
and sunk their ships down to the bottom
of the ocean because they knew there'd
be no going back in marine fort however
the marines were 100 prepared for the
arriving pirates and were still caught
off guard by whitebeard ships that came
up out of the water right in the same
relative location where the samurai sunk
their ships respectively furthermore the
raid on ogoshima is a private affair
happening on an isolated island while
the battle for marine ford was a public
one and broadcast to the whole world the
purpose of both battles is also
relatively similar to save and air in
marine ford the figure is ace who
happens to be the blood son of goldie
roger and the metaphorical son of the
emperor whitebeard in onigoshima
thematically speaking luffy is saving
two heirs who represent both halves of
aces identity momonosuke
first we'll start with momo the rightful
heir to the wano shogunate he was thrust
20 years into the future by his mother
toki and if you remember ace was held in
his mother rouge's womb not for 20 years
but for 20 months physically sending him
into the future he also happens to be 20
years old during ford and what's more is
both momo and ace are put on display for
execution which was where ace's true
parentage was revealed and he hides from
that identity as long as he can on the
other hand momo doesn't shy away from
his heritage and proudly declares who he
is in that moment the other half of ace
is yogato kaido's son by blood while ace
is loyal and protective of his adopted
father's whitebeard
wants to break their chains and end
their relationship with kaido luffy
frees both by removing their handcuffs
and the resultant poses after the
explosion are eerily similar and
speaking of kaido kaido is a total and
complete inversion of whitebeard both
are introduced into the series as quote
the strongest kaido is obsessed with
strength and death finding new ways to
attempt suicide to leave a lasting
legacy rather than truly caring about
his subordinates whitebeard values life
on the other hand and his crew above all
else this is shown through their actions
on the battlefield as well more
specifically in their endings whitebeard
holds a grudge against blackbeard who
gangs up with his nine other crewmates
to kill the emperor a tragic end to an
amazing man's life kaido's fight on
onigishima begins because of odin's
20-year grudge a man who lives on in the
spirit of his nine retainers who all
gang up on the emperor to catch him off
guard but the biggest hint towards a
larger inversion comes from odin's
flashback at the start of act three in
more ways than one odin whitebeard and
roger are metaphorical inversions of
sabo ace and luffy odin and sabo are
both royalty and run away from home but
odin's family disowns him allowing him
to travel into the ugliest part of the
country until he returns as a man
revered by all he eventually gets to
live his dream and travel the world as a
pirate meanwhile sabo's family does not
disown him at all the better part of his
young life is spent hiding from his
heritage while his parents bring in
steli as a replacement steli by the way
is a completeness version of orochi both
of whom come to power in completely
different ways within the royal
structure but unlike odin sabo doesn't
get to travel the world at least in the
flashback he is killed by a celestial
dragon using a gun odin is also killed
by a dragon kaido using a handgun by the
time roger arrived odin had already
developed a brotherly bond with
whitebeard much the same way sabo and
ace already had a relationship before
luffy was thrust upon them but luffy was
the weakest of the three and wined all
the time as opposed to roger's
incredible strength and charisma it's
also important to note that odin's
flashback tells the end of roger's
journey while the asl flashback details
the star of luffy's and there are a
multitude of visual inversions
throughout but the most obvious comes
when luffy and roger both declare their
dreams in front of the other two the
bandages are exactly the same as their
counterparts but whitebeard and odin's
reactions are inversions of ace and
sabo's and one last note odin's
flashback happens at the beginning of
act 3 before the main battle while asl
happens after marine ford's climax and
so well if act 3 is marine 4 then act 2
must be
[Music]
hey
hey i've seen this one i've seen this
one this is a classic after losing his
first battle with kaido luffy is
captured and imprisoned in udon against
his will and while presented with the
opportunity he chooses not to escape and
instead takes over the prison himself in
impel down luffy breaks into an
inescapable prison gets captured gains
allies and leaves before getting
captured again magellan is the warden of
impul down he has eaten the poison
poison fruit and luffy cannot physically
touch him without suffering significant
damage magellan's final poison eats
through everything and is essentially
instant death forcing luffy to run away
as fast as he can back in udon the de
facto ruler is queen a man famous for
creating plagues one of his viruses
called mummy is the biggest obstacle
luffy faces at the end of act two rather
than opting to run away from the highly
contagious plague luffy stands firm and
weathers the effects in order to inspire
the prisoners to rise up and rebel his
speech in udon is also a complete
inversion of his being on death's door
in impel down where bon clay and the
rest of level 5.5 cheer him on to stay
alive through his first near-fatal
encounter with miguel now one of the
cornerstones to impil down's plot has to
be the presence of blackbeard and the
effects he had on the facility and his
counterpart in wano's second act is
[Music]
big mom how do these relate to each
other well each has a previously
established relationship with the main
emperor of the ark blackbeard was
whitebeard's crewmate big mom was kaidos
they each break into the main prison but
the difference is one of identity
blackbeard broke into impel down because
of his connection to the world
government as a warlord and big mom
broke in while dealing with amnesia she
had no idea who she even was luffy is
also responsible for finding living
legends within the prison ivankov and
impelled down and hyogoro in udot iva is
leading a resistance underground while
hyogero has practically given up on life
out in the open each arc also features
an imprisoned fishman who becomes a
valuable ally jinbe and kawamatsu just
two of the many parallels between
luffy's gathered allies by the way
furthermore there's a moment late in
impel down where everyone frantically
rushes to the exit only to find no ships
present to help them escape jinbe has to
jump onto the ocean and carry a parody
with him to capture one of the fleeing
ships this is inverted by the promised
port that starts in act 3. the
scabbard's planned gathering at takage
port has gone awry with every sign of
their organized fleet destroyed later it
is revealed that all the ships are ok
including luffy and his allies and they
set sail where they meet the familiar
face jinbei now there's a reason why
these inversions are so difficult to
notice outright the majority of the
story elements from impul down have been
blended together throughout oneo's arc
for instance the great prison structure
is inverted by the order of the floors
on kaido's mansion one goes up and the
other goes down the theme of each of the
impelled down floors actually appears in
different locations throughout wano also
the first floor of impel down features
hundreds of knives that slash prisoners
until death in one of the slasher camazo
is the first true threat to the populace
the second floor of impel down is beast
hell which might as well be a stand-in
for kaido's army level 3 starvation hell
is represented by the townsfolk of wano
who are being starved thanks to orochi's
gluttony level 4 the blazing hell is
present in name thanks to queen sumo's
inferno but also by lord odin's boiling
death scene which is a clear callback to
the cauldron at the bottom of the level
level 5 the freezing hell is a manga
spoiler and i won't spoil it here but it
shouldn't be too hard for you all to
find if you have read it and finally
level 6 eternal hell is inverted by
ringo's burial grounds for more context
there the prisoners on level 6 are being
erased from history while ringo's has
what are known as eternal graves where
swords are used as grave markers to
honor their former masters lives moving
on it's time for act one oh my god are
you naked luffy washes up on the shores
of both islands alone needing to find
his friends on amazon lily that's his
driving purpose he fears the worst may
have just happened to his crew on one oh
however he assumes his friends can
handle themselves additionally on amazon
lilly luffy learns that his brother ace
has been captured and it completely
changes his thought process in act 1
luffy delivers the news of ace's death
to a local girl tama who had a close
connection with ace in each of these
luffy clashes with the island's culture
on amazon lily his ignorance of haki is
nearly his downfall but through sheer
force of will luffy survives and gains
valuable allies in one-o luffy learns
first-hand his haki isn't good enough in
a direct confrontation with kaido and he
loses in a brutal fashion well that
takes care of wano and so next up is the
reverie as it inverts some elements from
shavaldi
world leaders including many of the
straw hats allies come together to
discuss important matters and realize
the impact that luffy has had on a
global stage in shabaldi the opposite is
true luffy reaches a whole new
understanding and appreciation for how
vast and powerful the rest of the world
truly is and it tears his crew apart
celestial dragon st carlos tries to
capture a mermaid in both arcs and is
attacked in equal measure for doing so
in shabbat luffy punches him and causes
a war to break out on the island while
in reverie his defeat actually prevents
further violence additionally shabbat
also reveals that the world government
has called the remaining members of the
seven warlords together to face
whitebeard at marineford reverie on the
other hand is actually responsible for
disbanding the seven warlords altogether
and last but not least reverie ends with
a mystery who is emu the puppet master
putting the strings behind the world
government only their right eye is shown
and at the start of shabbat luffy and
company run into the flying fish riders
who have a mysterious leader also in
duval his true identity is left hidden
underneath his helmet at first with only
his right eye visible
next up whole cake island
due to its massive size and depth of
content it should come as no surprise
that whole cake island structure is a
smash cut of more than one arc this time
specifically water 7 ene's lobby and
thriller bark multiple arcs from
paradise providing material for those
new world arcs will become much more
commonplace from here on out what can i
say arcs are longer in the new world
water 7 is responsible for two of the
biggest emotional gut punches in the
series robin and usop leaving the crew
whole cake island chooses to merge their
two plotlines together in sanji's
decision to leave however robin leaves
and helps a secret government agency of
highly trained assassins target one of
water 7's leaders not just because of
her past but ultimately to help save the
straw hat crew from annihilation she did
not believe luffy and company could defy
the world government for her sake in
sanji's case he was born into a famous
cybernetically crafted kingdom of super
soldiers that eventually falls out of
favor with the world government they
threaten to destroy his cooking skills
and kill his adoptive extended families
zeph and the crew at the parody if he
does not follow through with their
arranged wedding plans also visually
garma 66 or g66 is an inversion of
cipher pole number 9 or cp9 but sanji
never manages to force luffy into
accepting his departure however unlike
robin he has a direct one-on-one
confrontation with his captain a jewel
similar to that of luffy's jewel with
usop sanji claims that he has everything
he ever wants and calls luffy a
miserable inferior pirate he's
attempting to discard the straw hats in
a similar fashion to how usof felt the
crew was discarding the merry for a new
ship and unlike the duel with usop luffy
never retaliates he allows sanji to kick
him over and over until he collapses
bloodied on the floor as each jewel ends
the physical victor luffy in water 7 and
sanji in whole cake island is left
crying usop leaves after losing to luffy
sanji leaves after defeating luffy and
ultimately when robin and sanji finally
both break down and admit their true
feelings the circumstances are also
entirely different robin is the one who
repents after verbally admonishing luffy
and the crew for coming to any lobby
declaring to the entire island i want to
live take me out to sea with you but in
whole cake island luffy physically
punches sanji forcing him to come to his
senses and declare in a private setting
i want to return to the sunny one of the
most interesting aspects we noticed of
whole cake islands and versions came in
the form of the ark skipping the
individual fights of indy's lobby in
favor of highlighting luffy's one-on-one
battle with katakuri the easy parallel
being of course luffy vs luchi both
fights center around the concept of
protecting the straw hat crew one as
they frantically tried to rescue robin
and the other as they frantically tried
to leave toto land in order to better
combat luchi luffy had to teach himself
gear 2 and 3 levelling the playing field
between him and cp9 but in combat with
katakuri luffy realizes he's outmatched
and forces himself to elevate his haki
throughout the course of battle his
challenge is to achieve this elevation
in ability while participating within
the constraints of the battle itself
what's interesting however is that
katakuri quickly dispatches the
techniques luffy used to defeat lucci
with which raises the question where
does the rest of the fight draw its
inspiration from the answer it might
surprise you
it comes from ryuma's battles on
thriller bark just on a visual level
both katakuri and ryuma are the most
reliable underlings of both arcs and
both were scarves ryuma's fight with
brooks showed that even if both
characters know the exact same moves
power determines the winner of the
battle the exact same lesson katakuri
tries to beat into luffy ryuma's battle
with zoro is also a key piece here we
see the end result of the fight before
we flashback to see how it progressed as
an audience we literally see the future
and the entirety of luffy vs katakuri is
about the straw hat captain training his
observation haki to see into the future
himself zoro and ryuma's final clash
shows the moments just after the final
blow has been landed while luffy vs
katakuri features a simultaneous
exchange that shows the moments just
before each move lands and last but not
least the ending poses of each fight are
eerily similar also here ryuma and
katakuri each stand tall with luffy and
zorro lying on the ground in seeming
defeat
both antagonists then concede each
having gained mutual respect for the
other fighter finally on the topic of
whole cake island one of the most
important thematic inversions comes in
the climax both luffy and sanji striving
to accomplish their goals by 1am each of
them powered by the fate their crew has
in them their two-panel declaration
beautifully parallels usopp speech to
robin aboard the c train imploring her
to have faith in luffy there's honestly
so so much more to this arc in terms of
inversions but for the sake of time and
for the sake of overflowing your brains
with more information we gotta press
onward to zou long ring long land jaya
and skypia
even the surest new world arcs are
amalgamations of three paradise arcs and
zou is no different here first the
island itself is an inversion of long
ring long land zou is really zunesia a
nomadic elephant that wanders the seas
seemingly without aim with a fantastical
community of humanoid animals called
minks living on its back long ring-long
land is a circular chain of 10 islands
paths between the islands only surface
once a year forcing the community of
people living on the island to develop a
nomadic culture and long-ring long land
has its own set of interesting animals
too but zou also pulls a lot of
parallels from both skypia and jaya ota
calls skypia a wandering island once zou
certainly fits that category and both
feature the ruins of ancient kingdoms
specifically speaking the flashbacks are
the key here mont blanc noland and the
great warrior kalgara were fast friends
but their relationship was severed the
moment skypia was knocked up into the
sky when luffy rang the golden bell at
the end of skypia its ringing
colloquially referred to as the song of
the island not only signaled the end to
the 400-year war but it also reached and
connected the ancestors of noland and
calgary cricket and viper respectively
on zou the elephant has been waiting to
hear one voice momentous case it begged
him for an order to retaliate on the
ships that were firing on his leg momo
finally relented and zanesha defeated
jack and so by the law of inversion you
could say that the bell was asking the
island's inhabitants permission to
defeat inel back to noland and kalgara
for a moment however their fast
friendship is the complete antithesis of
dog storm and cat vipers present on zo
each pair also deal with a devastating
plague noland a botanist and doctor has
to convince the natives that the plague
isn't the wrath of god and thanks to
modern medicine it's now a curable
disease meanwhile chopper and the half
of the straw hat crew that arrived on
zou have to convince the minks that
they're here to help before crafting a
cure for caesar's special gas chopper's
newfound skill with botany was
specifically highlighted too in this arc
jaya's presence is most evident in the
mink king's first meeting with the
samurai every single mink on the island
did whatever they could to keep jack
from knowing rizo's whereabouts they
feigned ignorance fought and were nearly
wiped out in the process but held firm
to their beliefs that it was a fight
worth their lives luffy faced the
opposite situation on jaya he and his
crew were looking for information on
traveling to sky island and they were
practically laughed out of the bar in
moktown for believing in fairy tales
luffy and zoro were humiliated and
beaten but never fought back it wasn't a
battle or an opponent that was worth
their time and upon exiting the bar they
stumbled upon blackbeard who they didn't
know at the time he offered his respect
and in a legendary spread declared that
dreams will never end a near total
thematic inversion to the minx
declaration that rhizo is safe
moving on it's time for dress rosa
[Music]
[Laughter]
by now even the speed readers should
have noticed the parallels between
alabasta and dressrosa they're the same
picture from the kingdoms to the
princesses vv viola and rebecca to the
main villains of doflamingo and
crocodile and their respective crews we
could add another 25 minutes to this
video's runtime detailing all the
callbacks present but luckily for us the
entirety of the inversion can be
eloquently summarized by these two
panning spreads from episode 957 of the
anime the main difference between the
two arcs is that dressrosa is what would
have happened had crocodile succeeded in
becoming the hero of alabasta crocodile
runs a secret organization and works in
the shadows while doflamingo rules over
a slimy underground trading ring and
makes no real secret of it even their
defeats are inversions in alabasta
crocodile is defeated in a secret battle
underground punched through sheer
bedrock until he's blasted into the sky
exposing him and his plot for the entire
country to see meanwhile in dressrosa
luffy only arrives on the scene after
the entire country is chanting his name
and in a climactic clash he cast
douflamingo out of the sky and back into
the depths where he belongs demolishing
the ground below and of course smoker is
giving full credit for taking down
crocodile so the world government can
better cover up the events compare that
with admiral fujitora making a very
public apology to king riku precisely so
that the world government can't cover it
up but of course there's plenty of
callbacks to giant skypie here as well
first doflamingo shares characteristics
with an l both are gods one by birth the
other by self-appointment each rule from
the sky but the most important thematic
inversion is the presence of a natural
enemy luffy is inel's natural enemy
because he is made of rubber a perfect
conductor to inel's lightning but as
explained by corazon in law's flashback
the d-clan are also known as god's
natural enemy god in this case means
celestial dragon so luffy is also
doflamingo's natural enemy doflamingo's
bird cage is even technically present in
skypia it's om's ordeal of iron this is
yet another example of oda blending
inversions across an arc doflamingo's
devil fruit power is sure as ordeal of
string the tauntatus to basketball is
the ordeal of balls and the ordeal of
swamp well hold on to that thought for
just a moment before we move on to punk
hazard i want to talk about bellamy
luffy's second battle with bellamy
mirrors his first with bellamy shifting
his utter disgust to newfound respect
for the young pirate and as if to cement
this theory luffy only throws one punch
in each fight he uses his right hand on
jaya and his left hand on dress rosa
next up
punk hazard the first island the straw
hats come across in the new world punk
hazard is composed of inversions of the
three islands they first encounter on
the ground line before we get to whiskey
peak when luffy and company first enter
the ground line they run into lagoon a
massive whale who is simultaneously
treated by a doctor crocus trying to
help him find his adoptive family and at
the start of punk hazard the crew enter
the new world alongside a pod of whales
that look like lagoon they quite
literally are with their family whiskey
peak was an island that had all sorts of
visitors as it was one of the first
stops on the grand line they roll out
the welcome carpet to pirates to stop by
and celebrate hoping to lure them into a
trap so the members of the barrack works
can collect their bounties punk hazard
on the other hand does not exist on the
log post in fact it was deemed
uninhabitable and its residents exist in
secret both arcs are centered around
saving royalty in princess vivi and
momonosuke each hiding their respective
identities and lastly punk hazard makes
no real secret of the overarching
villain doflamingo's involvement he
remains physically and verbally present
throughout while crocodile remains
shrouded in mystery during the build-up
to the alabasta arc so how about
littlegarden that arc centered around an
ancient jewel between giants dory the
blue and brogie the red they battled
every day for 100 years and actually
forgot the reason for their legendary
fight punk hazard on the other hand
quite literally is shaped by the jewel
between two massive powers aokiji which
translates to blue pheasant and akainu
which means red dog the reason for their
duel is known globally the winner would
become fleet admiral of the marines now
aokiji and akainu may not physically be
present in punk hazard but there are
still two giants who live on the island
the yeti cool brothers a tag team group
of assassins that show mastery of combat
in the snow their footprints look eerily
similar to the giant footprints shown
before luffy and coast set foot on
little garden and a quick note on smiley
and land of the dead here land out the
dead in japanese is shino kuni the name
and massive form evoke memories of the
island eater which in japanese
translates to shima kui in its geisha's
form land of the dead petrifies its
victims trapping them in a hardened
shell the imagery it evokes is a perfect
mirror to mr three's candle service set
which is set up to kill zorro nami and
vivi on little garden by covering them
in wax it cascades over punk hazard like
a raging avalanche a perfect transition
to drums many inversions let's talk
doctors hiroduke's dream is realized at
the end of the drum arc by kureha a
massive display of pink dust coating
snow in the shape of a tree on the
island it lights up the sky and
represents hope for a kingdom that truly
needed it caesar on the other hand was
incredibly jealous of vegapong to the
point that he recklessly unleashes a
prototype of his gaseous weapon that
turned punk hazard into a wasteland both
moans share the image of a mushroom
cloud but both carry opposing meanings
to that imagery and while the image of
cherry blossoms might be inverted there
the message itself is inverted elsewhere
in projecting the pink dust into the sky
kudeja is sending off her adopted son
chopper with her blessing the phrase she
uses is go on you foolish boy
thematically that statement is the
opposite of law cutting virgo and the
entire island in half he claims to have
destroyed the proverbial gears
specifically stating that no one can
turn back one final note on this section
that i thought was pretty cool on the
cruise way to alabasta nami falls ill
but still managed to steer the crew
clear of a massive typhoon however on
their way to the new world she's
otherwise occupied taking a bath before
the sunny gets sucked into a massive
white storm an underwater typhoon
alrighty so we've covered a lot of
material here we've made it through both
paradise and the current parts of the
new world and the order of those arcs
follow a very similar overarching
pattern the question now is what about
the east blue does it follow the same
order the answer is no instead of
getting logtown's inverse prior to
entering the new world we get arlong
park
it is ridiculously obvious that fishman
island's primary inversion comes from
arlong park the current circumstances of
fishman island were created by a single
act of kindness from whitebeard he
arrived on the island one day and
declared that it was now his territory
saving the populace from poaching by
pirate crews who passed through this is
a perfect inversion to arlang who
arrived in the shores of kokoyashi
village and announced that it was now
under his rule hodi quite literally
takes from arlen but he represents a
total inversion of arlon's character
arlong actually dealt with and
experienced human hatred towards fishman
hodi simply absorbed the hatred without
experiencing it himself both are the
respective leaders of their movements
and both have an elevated berserker
state that they attain in the final
battle with luffy but each have very
different priorities when luffy shields
himself from an attack by using one of
arlon's men arlang is enraged and
distraught at the thought of hurting one
of his own hodi shows no such moral
compass using a nearby ally to shield
himself from one of zoro's flying
slashes again there are numerous
one-to-one inversions between both acts
but this is where the theory really gets
interesting in order to make either the
story more cohesive or because it felt
appropriate oda took aspects from other
story beats outside of just the main
inverted arcs in this case fishman
island happens to also be a natural
inversion to skypia one is in the sky
the other is underwater the straw hats
shoot up into the white white sea via
the knock-up stream while they get shot
down into the depths of the pitch-black
ocean via the underwater waterfall on
the way back down from skypie they
encounter an octopus balloon that allows
them to float easily downwards and on
the way down to fishman island they run
into a massive octopus that they have to
tame the kraken several of the most
impactful visual inversions of the
entire series come in this arc and
really these visual choices were what
initially sold me on this theory in the
first place inel's maxim is a weapon of
mass destruction completed by enslaving
the populace there's a beautiful shot
towards the tail end of the story where
a defeated inel rides maxim to the moon
and he gazes longingly at his end goal
contrast that with noah a ship created
centuries ago for a benevolent purpose
and promise now being used as a weapon
as it begins its descent towards fishman
island the ark is now massive in the
foreground a perfect inversion of the
moon shot from skypia upon defeating
inel and ringing the bell for the very
first time luffy's celebratory shadow is
cast over the clouds connecting the
descendants of montblanc cricket and
kalgara and fulfilling a generations
long promise contrast that with noah's
first appearance over the sky and
fishman island a promise has not been
kept and instead of joy king neptune is
struck with horror at its mere presence
and now with skype in the mix hodi's
inversion becomes a little clearer he's
a combination of both arlong and inel
inel destroyed his homeland of burqa and
traveled to skypia hodi is basically
threatening to do the same both wield
tritons that have superiority over luffy
in their respective battles due to his
debilitating circumstances against the
now luffy had to fight the latter stages
of the conflict with a massive golden
ball attached to his arm against hodi
luffy is inside a ball-shaped bubble
that restricts his movements as well
[Music]
if you've been subscribed for a while
you'll know i keep my balls in great
shape thanks to my previous manscape
partnership to keep my manly jojo body
in check this time however we're back on
the high seas with one piece and that
means i'm gonna need some brand new
equipment introducing the lawnmower 4.0
now fully waterproof wireless and
featuring a brand new handy-dandy travel
lock system to prevent battery drain on
the move i can set sail with renewed
confidence in my perfectly sculpted man
garden if you remember the last time my
gummu gumbos were the topic of the day
you might recall i had pretty sensitive
skin thankfully the lawnmower 4.0 new
skin safe tech is here to save the day
once again no cuts smooth trimming
adjustable guards i have total
confidence here and it is totally
pain-free one of the coolest new
features however is the wireless
charging system doubling is a handy
stand for the mower this thing charges
fast and is great for up to 90 minutes
on a full battery it really is the full
package for my package so if you're
looking to find the right tools for your
family jewels head over to manscape.com
and use promo code not mark 20 for 20
off plus free international shipping
your balls will thank you
[Music]
if the flow of the east blue inversions
was the same as the paradise inversions
we would naturally expect bharatiya to
show up before fishman island but it
doesn't instead we get the straw hat
cruise version of low town
the place that was the beginning and end
of roger's life should of course be
inverted by the death and rebirth of
luffy's crew in each setting the crew is
only there for a short amount of time
and they get outside help to escape from
the marines and in a poetic ending to
this recap the time skip begins the way
the first half of this series ends with
luffy picking up the hat that he had set
down of course that leaves us with a big
question where are the rest of the east
blue arcs where's broadway for example
well the answer might surprise you and
it's a massive manga spoiler so for
those who don't want to know use the
time codes below to skip ahead to my
predictions for the remainder of the
story
we are on the bharatiya right now
onigishima is baratier what better
inversion of the seafaring restaurant
shaped like a fish than an island held
in the sky by flames created by a user
of the fish fish fruit kaido echoes
krieg from their facial designs to their
craftiness and their seemingly
indestructible armor additionally they
are each in command of a massive pirate
crew known for their numbers and there's
an interesting name that was most
recently used in chapter 1014 as luffy
plummets from onigishima kaido remarks
that luffy couldn't be joy boy either
the inversion here on baratier luffy
earned a specific moniker for partially
destroying the restaurant the chefs on
staff called him choreboy not only does
it sound similar but it also seems like
it could potentially have an inverse
relationship to joyboy luffy gets out of
his choreboy duties by defeating krieg
which means he'll likely fully realize
his role as the carrier of joyboy's will
by defeating kaido and restoring wano
and hey remember zeph's log book the one
that we discussed in the beginning of
this video one that krieg hypothesized
contained information on the one piece
and its location it too has an inversion
odin's log book which now resides on one
o itself
how one piece will end and so that
brings us up to date to the end of the
map and faced with forecasting what's to
come over the horizon right now we have
three arcs left to invert romance dawn
town and syrup village to be clear
before we jump into this my theory is
not that the events will take place in
these locations but that they will
instead be inspired by them and in many
cases can be used to potentially predict
future events so let's see what we can
come up with here elbath in the current
order of inversion for east blue we
should expect syrup village's inversion
arc to come immediately after one the
one island that seems to be on
everyone's radar right now is elbaf and
i think this theory supports this idea
the name of the island itself is an
inversion of the word fable which if you
think about it makes complete sense as a
thematic inversion to syrup village if
used as a verb the term to fable means
to tell fictitious tales otherwise known
as lies and so it is my belief that
elbaf will come after wano as an
inversion for syrup village which had to
contend with usop's daily tall tales
what's more is that usop has wanted to
travel to elbaf since little garden so
there's little to no surprise that these
arcs would be connected thematically to
speculate as to what might take place
here is somewhat difficult to nail down
but given its significance for usopp i
would wager he will play a leading role
in the adventure that takes place it
could also very well be the location
where instead of his famous lies he will
be telling truths creating that scene
that we've all sort of predicted at one
point or another and present himself as
the warrior of the sea he set out to one
day become all those years ago another
possibility this land may very well
present to us is the long-awaited
reuniting of usopp and his father yasso
syrup village acted as the place where
he saw his mom pass on and his father
leave perhaps elbath will be the
location where he'll connect with him
once more undisclosed location a next up
orange town where we fittingly recruited
nami after dealing with a formidable
buggy the clown this one is still open
to interpretation there's a chance it
could be lodestar island for a lead
island packaged alongside shell town
from romans dawn or perhaps more likely
these separate islands i'm inverting in
the east blue might all be combined and
be covered thematically on elbaf making
elbaf one of the final islands visited
on this incredible voyage so just keep
in mind the locations of the remaining
material will be tenuous at best it's
honestly impossible to know how and when
oda will invert a pre-existing idea with
that said however piggybacking off of
the possible reuniting of yusup and his
father i think it's entirely possible
that this will be an opportunity for
luffy to reunite with shanks for the
majority of the story buggy the clown
and shanks have been shown to have a
shared history and so given that buggy
was a large part of orangetown it might
be fitting that shanks the other half of
their duo will play his role in this
material too perhaps they'll meet in
elbaf and perhaps that location might
explain why they call him chief shanks
instead of the much more colloquially
known moniker of captain shanks and
finally i'll only be guessing in this
situation but given that buggy's cannon
played a large role in the initial story
instead of the cannon perhaps
threatening the straw hats from some
outside force perhaps an inversion of
that could lead us nicely into an
endgame of the story as luffy and his
crew instigate the attack instead only
this time it backfires on them
undisclosed location b let's talk
shelltown thematically a self-promoting
marine tyrant ruling by overt fear
captain morgan has an easy inversion in
the secretive ruler of the world
government emu both of them are even
shrouded in shadow as they're first
introduced to the story the structure of
the island also bears a small
resemblance to marijoa so perhaps we'll
head there after elbaf who knows it's
difficult to discern whether or not the
greatest battle in all of one piece will
take place here in this segment or if it
will be over the one piece itself we'll
have to see how it all pans out but
regardless of what form it takes we've
been promised by oda himself a fight to
dwarf that of marine ford which is a
massively bold statement even for oda
undisclosed location c and that brings
us to the end of the series with fuchsia
village on dawn island where it all
began almost a quarter century ago with
a young man eager for friendship and
adventure being denied entry to the crew
while desperately trying to prove his
value in any way he could ultimately
dragging a man he admired into
life-threatening danger as a direct
result of his own mistake and so
what better way could this series end
than by having that one time child
return home as king of the pirates
surrounded by his friends and crew
without a single thing left to prove he
could attempt to give the straw hat back
to shanks too but we could go one step
further and predict that shanks will say
that the hat was never his that it was
always meant for luffy to wear the final
conclusion of this theory is that one
piece will end with a complete inversion
of the opening pages of the series which
details roger's final words at lowtown
by then the mystery will be solved
everyone will know what the one piece is
only this time unlike roger luffy
doesn't die alone he gets to live on
with his friends at his side still
having so much he wants to see and do in
the world and daring anyone else to come
after him and so the very reason why oda
has had the last chapter clear in his
mind from the very beginning of the
series back in 1997 is because back in
1997 oda had already written the first
chapter in other words all he had to do
was invert his already finished work
the one piece but okay i can hear some
of the gears turning in your brain where
would the inversion of laugh tale be
surely it has to be somewhere in the
east blue right well lucky for you this
theory has an answer or at least i think
it does
it's gaiman's island
the island of misfit creatures where
gaiman a man stuck in a treasure chest
spends his entire life unable to reach a
series of five treasure chests on the
top of a hill that happened to be empty
the inversion almost writes itself we
now know laughtail houses the ultimate
treasure and luffy will be the one to
announce it to the world a step further
and we could infer that luffy's hat the
thing he always travels with is an
inversion to gaimon's treasure chest
which means in some way shape or form
luffy's straw hat is in fact related to
the one piece or carries greater meaning
with regards to the d clan of course we
can take this a step further we now have
seen the very moment roger discovered
the great treasure maybe there's an
inversion in the first half of the grand
line that can unveil it for us well
there is in fact a mirror to roger's
famous laugh at laughtale as we
mentioned earlier odin's flashback is
based in part around the ace sabo luffy
flashback after sabo's apparent death
ace stares out across the ocean and
cries for a brief moment the world had
nothing to offer him a stark contrast to
roger discovering everything the world
had to offer and that finally brings us
to the ultimate purpose of inverting the
narrative to this degree yes it
absolutely does show how much the
story's characters have grown but in
reality i believe it has more to do with
the lingering will of d that exists in
the background luffy and blackbeard are
written as polar opposites they're seen
together in the baron jaya proves this
they are inversions of one another and
the very moment that signifies according
to this theory the middle of the story
or the midpoint of the inversions marine
ford ends at the lowest point of luffy's
life and the highest point in
blackbeard's with him having slain
whitebeard and having claimed the era
for himself one of the biggest mysteries
surrounding the will of d happens to be
that of the checkered fate with
checkered typically meaning a pattern
alternating between squares of lights
and darks recently throughout the new
world dawn has been referenced numerous
times and it seems to be correlated to
one of luffy's purposes in life bringing
light to those around him blackbeard on
the other hand always brings death and
destruction with his signature power
being that of darkness the inversion of
blackbeard telling luffy that dreams
never end on jaya was dog storm and cat
viper telling the samurai that rhizo was
safe downstorm happens to be lord of the
day while cat viper is lord of the night
on zou and along similar lines luffy is
the dawn and blackbeard is the dusk
they're both d's but their presence
comes one after another luffy is there
to build up what blackbeard tears down
as whitebeard says in his dying words
blackbeard isn't the man roger is
waiting for blackbeard claims his error
begins on marineford but in reality he's
misunderstanding his fated purpose for
being there he's ending whitebeard's era
and throwing everything into chaos so
now wano will be about luffy starting a
new era the same way roger did by
finding the one piece he will bring a
new dawn to the world
now
of course this is what we had put
together before chapter 1018 was
released and so now that we have some
remarkable new information let's take a
look behind the scenes and revisit a
couple of things so you can perhaps best
understand how we try to digest and
interpret this information as usual
massive spoilers are coming chapter 1018
reveals that there used to be a
legendary warrior a sun god called nika
slaves in ancient times would pray that
he would come and save them bringing
laughter along the way i don't think
there's a soul on the face of the planet
now that doesn't believe luffy is in
fact related in some way shape or form
to this sun god character and it only
strengthens our assertion that luffy
will bring about the dawn of the world
it's also not a stretch to say that
based on the shadowy outline presented
nika could in fact be joyboy himself and
last but not least the design also
harkens back to the shandians which is
only natural because we know that the
sun god was referenced several times
throughout skypia and that the world
government targeted shandora in the past
essentially wiping it out so if that's
the case that arc should be where we
find our inversion for joy boy we should
expect a flashback detailing what
happened in the void century to pull
from the nolan and kalgara flashback on
skype is so let's take a look the
character of kalgara himself could be a
joy boy inversion of sorts he's a
dogmatic serious man hell-bent on
protecting his country under a strict
religious doctrine this already sounds
like a great inversion to the very
concept of nika there is even a line in
the manga where after kalgara befriends
noland the fellow shandians remarked on
how they never had seen kalgaro laugh so
loudly before further implying his
serious demeanor in the past
additionally kalgara has not seen the
larger world and wants to hear all about
nolan's explorations while joyboy is a
figure who connected people around the
world now in that same breath nolan
could be a stand-in for roger you see
both were executed after finding a
mythical island the world at large
believed roger left his great treasure
at the end of the grand line but he
himself said that he was too early while
nolan returned to jaya too late shandya
had already been rocketed up into the
sky not to be seen by him ever again and
as a result everyone believed his tale
concerning the city of gold was a lie he
died in disgrace hoping kalgara his
friend was okay roger said that he
wished he could have been born in joy
boy's era inferring that he wish he
could have been friends with him he was
probably looking for the kind of
friendship nolan and kalgara had
together there are other elements that
point to a potential inversion with the
original poseidon namely the sacrificial
altar where kalgara nearly forces his
daughter to commit suicide it's already
somewhat implied that joyboy influenced
poseidon in a way that prevented her
from using her powers the wrong way for
some reason or another but perhaps most
interesting of all looking at that
flashback as guidance we may be able to
interpret what the one piece may in fact
be obviously this is all speculative but
it's fun to see how far we can stretch
this theory for potential answers so
let's give it a shot the ancient city of
shandora could be inverted by the
mysterious ancient kingdom chandora's
treasure was the golden belfry which
generated a beautiful tone and provided
light amidst the stormy seas the sound
of this bell ringing was always intended
to connect people from the past to the
present and eventually even the future
and it was specifically referenced as
the song of the island throughout skypia
even beyond that flashback so what we're
looking for now is a song surely there
must be a song for laugh tale something
that would be the opposite of the bell's
ringing something that didn't disappear
and exist in the hearts and minds of
people across the world connecting them
on their journeys we thought long and
hard about this and really
only one song fit that billing the song
for laugh tale
is binx's sake
the lyrics are the key here namely three
verses the first
if you lose your nerve this breath could
be your last but if you hold on the
morning sun will rise with the next
first ending with waving our goodbyes
will never meet again but don't look so
down for tomorrow night the moon will
also rise the song literally details our
analysis of the will of d's checkered
fate and even more than that the final
verse specifically states never ending
ever wondering our funny traveling tale
that last bit untranslated is what i
banashi which literally means
laugh tale
roger was the one who named the final
island and if our theory is correct he
likely named it that because of this
song they sang it all the way there
through stormy seas just like nolan
heard the great bells ringing on his way
to jaya
so is that the treasure i mean it's
important to remember that the world at
large are the ones who coined the term
one piece not roger or joy boy himself
and if there's one thing this series has
taught us it's that treasure is always
in the eye of the beholder there might
not be anything better for joy boy a man
who loves to make people smile than a
song that will withstand the test of
time and bring joy to all who hear it
maybe there's a version written on the
island that has lyrics detailing the
specifics of joy boy's story not to
mention it would be a great payoff for
how hell ben luffy was on recruiting a
musician or maybe we should now look at
the bell itself for a potential
inversion kalgara said that the gold
wasn't as important as the information
written on the poneglyph so perhaps in
this case we are looking for something
physical what is the inversion of a bell
well how about we literally just rotate
it and suddenly it looks like
a cup
a cup to store binks's sake to be passed
amongst your friends what else has luffy
been doing at the end of every arc other
than celebrating with all of his friends
what better way to end a long journey
than with another magnificent
celebration to end all celebrations this
time with the whole world with everyone
free to love and laugh as much as they
want it would also have close ties to
western mythology luffy finally
attaining the holy grail of this series
now obviously there are a few holes in
this theory with one being that it
doesn't explain why roger felt he was
too early i mean perhaps to roger that
celebration couldn't happen with fishman
and other races harshly treated across
the world and so perhaps it's a
celebration the entire world needs to
partake in but hey that's just a theory
an anime theory
this has been one hell of a journey the
fact that there's this much nuance in a
story that has been meticulously crafted
over the past quarter century is
mind-boggling and to be clear there's
definitely a chance that this theory's
prediction is wrong i mean there are
even east blue inversions in wano proper
but even with that in mind oda has had
no qualms about inverting earlier scenes
multiple times remember how nl traveling
up to the moon was inverted visually by
noah falling into fishman island i mean
that scene is actually inverted again in
reverie when shirahoshi finally gets a
chance to see the sun as the fishman
travels up to marijoa it is definitely
possible that the ending of this series
will go in a completely different
direction never seen before it is also
possible that inversions will continue
to pull from earlier arcs merging and
painting them in a very different light
as we have outlined above i mean the
very nature of aldo's inversions makes
it impossibly difficult to predict
everything that will come up i mean who
could have predicted that fat water
luffy from alabastec would be an
inversion of gear four
my own one piece journey which spans six
months of 2020 brought with it many ups
and downs and unexpected turns but by
far the best aspect of that adventure i
embarked on that i've mentioned time and
again whenever asked was the community
that participated in the videos and the
creative talented individuals that
became known as my one piece secret
service without them not only would that
series not have been nearly as good as
it was but i would never in a million
years have come across this theory this
theory is very much the brainchild of
one specific person and her name is
rachel this theory and idea is the
product of countless rereads of the
series and her love of the franchise and
so this is where you guys come in i
think we've really got something on our
hands with this theory personally and if
one piece has taught me anything it's
that no matter how passionate and
talented someone is they will need help
from their friends to reach their goal
and so this is where i hand this theory
over to you the one piece community
together there's a possibility that with
this theory and the combined effort of
the wider one-piece community we just
might be able to identify the inversions
that will lead us to the one piece
treasure i think we're looking in the
right place personally we just need a
little help below in the description of
this video you'll find a link to a text
document that rachel herself wrote it's
very long and contains far far more
inversions i didn't even mention in this
video detailing the inversions
concerning events that haven't yet even
been adapted by the manga and so if you
feel like diving into this theory a bit
more and perhaps discovering for
yourself some inversions that even we
missed i encourage you to check it out
one piece is a series that keeps giving
and this video has been one of the most
rewarding and fun projects to work on i
want to again extend a massive thank you
to rachel for effectively writing this
video for me and discovering this theory
and so her social media links are also
in the description be sure to send her
some love and a follow she's amazing but
for now i leave this theory in your
hands personally i think there's too
much to this theory for it to be just a
coincidence and perhaps out there
watching this video right now is a
person who using this theory could piece
together more answers from it but until
then i've been tolynotmark thank you all
so much for watching
and i'll see you all in the next video
[Music]
you